pay the expense on right now
i want your love
i need your love oh [ __ ]
and i want it to be real
i want your love
give me your love
e
okay
church of what's happening now is
presented by honest
i was just saying today that i'm growing
to love
my hello tushy more and more every day i
can't live without it and you know what
guys the days are back the church of
what's happening now is proud to present
you with to hellotushy.com
hellotushy.com makes portable devices
that spray your butt clean with water
that's right it sounds funny but it's
completely true go to hellotushy.com
church right now to get 10 off of your
order
where's that musically kick that [ __ ]
meal [ __ ]
it's the church of what's happening now
hiddenly
oh [ __ ] oh
oh [ __ ]
wednesday january 4th [ __ ] the day
the devil was buried at sea
uncle joey nick the turo
my main man lee siyati [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] why [ __ ] around it's thursday
morning take a chance columbus did
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] freeze it time to bring out the
gorilla biscuits
here we go
[Music]
here we go [ __ ] let's go
[Music]
and you thought it was going to be a
blase type of [ __ ] day
yeah
what's up you bad [ __ ] uncle
joey here my main men nick deturo
and the [ __ ] flying jew himself lisa
hanukkah's over yom kippur is over
[ __ ] it
lent is on the way lee it ain't your
type of season there's nothing to look
forward to all we have is pass over and
that sucks what are you gonna do what's
happening nicky all right buddy great to
be here great to have you let's make it
a better showed up with wine bread
[ __ ] sauce we're going deep into the
murky waters we've been eating stars
lee didn't get sick tonight they were
out of chocolate
you lucked out they were out of this i
told you i tried my first chocolate in
seattle and what'd you think so in
seattle you just walk in on this yeah
you just walked in and said uh
it just said like you know i don't know
what it just looked like a you know said
come in and you lived in downtown so you
were no i was in the suburbs kent
washington washington it was like right
up the street i got arrested there did
you yeah one of those places
possession of stolen car but the car
wasn't stolen that'll let me go after
three days
they kept me in there for 72 [ __ ]
hours because they pinched me on a
friday those [ __ ] yeah but that's
why you gotta make a move so you don't
have to spend the whole weekend and uh
and you don't have to go follow the
judge you know my cousin one time
he he made out that he was having a
heart attack on a friday he got pinched
so then he spent the whole weekend he
threw himself on the ground and faked
the heart attack and then because he
knew he would have been in jail all
weekend sucks dick i know because i'm
tired when you got plans and [ __ ] for
the weekend you know
that you are in county jail at six
o'clock and [ __ ] oh my god
for like [ __ ] years
the worst one was i got paid i was with
my girlfriend also in the [ __ ] car
wash she starts to fight and she rips up
half the [ __ ] check and i take it
from when some guy goes hey leave her
alone i didn't do nothing oh you were
having a fight and then somebody yeah in
seattle and i had to hide in the
dumpster
and the cops were looking for me all
afternoon and when i got out of the
dumpster i walked 10 feet and they're
the cops waiting for him wow what a
[ __ ] nightmare seattle's a freaking
strange town
i got used to it but but but it's a
strange strange very bohemian the maluk
yeah listen it's the the bremerton
washington is the deepest point that's
where my dad was in the navy yeah
because it's the deepest point that's
where the submarines are they got pretty
girls up there nobody everything is
great the guys are all coming in
the tip shits the guys they all look
very like
dorky my stepbrother's uncle lives all
the way up there when i went up there
robert ronnie i [ __ ] contacted him
one time this is 94.95 you know i used
to go to bremerton
but it's a growing city oh yeah now it's
kind of smart all that you know uh all
those
computer guys are up there you know is
all that was it hello amazon or who's up
there everybody's everybody's up there
right there i wouldn't know i'm not
allowed up there 1995. you can't go
you're banned this is 97 20 years now
i'm
20 [ __ ] years i still got that
warrant out wow it's a non-extraditional
warrant they could only arrest me if
they find me in the state of washington
in that state they won't come in you
don't do no comedy there [ __ ] no no i
don't go nowhere i got the milk put on
yeah
it was like let me tell you something it
was like
i was going through a rough patch in my
life
and then i moved to seattle
and i didn't know what malloy was until
i moved like i thought i was going
through i was going i was like on a
two-year skid
on a two years scared of death
and i finally moved to seattle and i get
pinched five times and eighteen thousand
would you get pinched from you name it
assault possession of stolen car
[ __ ] violating or it was a [ __ ] and
it all started with a jaywalking ticket
why'd you go there anyway because i met
a girl oh why the [ __ ] would anybody go
no i mean too not a girl i know i don't
think i ever would have went to that
place my father used to talk about it
because he was in the navy and he
stopped there and i asked my mom i said
why does he always talk about that watch
because i probably shacked up with some
girls when he was young he was a good
looking guy i always talked about
washington washington that first few
times i was like i hate this place it's
weird you know it took me a while to
like you know kind of embrace it
i went up there at the time for comedy
and for this girl so i moved in with her
and i got a place and then i just did
comedy and compared to where i was
living in denver and boulder at the time
this was i was going out every night
they had comedy every [ __ ] night yeah
every night they had comedy somewhere
kent
uh
burlingham what's what's all the way up
there uh bramington bremerton yeah i
used no no bellingham bellingham
bellingham kent there was a lady who
booked every single like that you have
you know like
they have these mexican chains around
here like what's the taco place we go to
we go to cactus cactus okay cactus would
have 11 restaurants and all of them
would do comedy
so the one in kent would do comedy the
one in
eastern over the bridge and uh
the east side of seattle would do comedy
yeah the one in
tacoma would do comedy the one on in in
portland
like close to portland with new comedy i
forget what they would call low
something
mexican restaurant so there was action
everything different vibe northwest is
really different and when you're doing
it in a restaurant are you doing it at
like the bar like what are you [ __ ]
barley okay and how many people how many
people would come to like a mexican
restaurant 14
15 tops what was your act like back then
just god awful really got off what'd you
talk about who the [ __ ] knows killing
people and kidnapping people and selling
drugs who the [ __ ] a lot of serial
killers up there you know the green lake
uh guy oh yeah bundy yeah money was up
in seattle yeah like intelligent but
dark
crazy people well that place a lot of
people ice themselves up there buffalo
yeah buffalo too it's the same type of
well i look at that nicer city than
buffalo yeah well and i like buffalo i'm
a buffalo dude yeah i'm a i'm a rough
and rugged i'm a rick tam james type of
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
yeah
you know but i i take it like i'm a wing
dude i like the the beef on the way is
it good to be found you ever seen that
movie buffalo 66 good movie movies
what happened to him he lost his mind he
lost his mind yeah he was crazy he was
crazy that's why he made a movie where
he had a girl like you know actually do
something to him on camera
for real it's in the movie it's called
bugs bunny or something
and uh yeah he said he's definitely out
there he was a talented guy yeah that's
why i love that movie i love that movie
that's right vincent gazara is in it he
plays father yeah oh my god angelica
houston is the mother wearing the bill's
jacket
that's right yeah watch that again
that's a fun i used to stop in buffalo
to go to toronto i was doing a movie i'd
never passport so i used to go i could
get in from
buffalo to toronto like with a birth
certificate
one time this is before 9 11. yeah
before 9 11 you could [ __ ] wave at
him i never went through the border
because in fact i got to call this kid
he called me irish dating the puerto
rican girl in my how [ __ ] up is this
i'm talking to i'm talking to the waiter
at the miami improv and i go dog i got
to work in [ __ ] buffalo next week and
then i got to jump over to canada and
work toronto
i don't think they're going to let me
over this way before 9 11. and he goes
bro i could get your hand like that like
what are you talking about my girl's
father
this is how nice these puerto ricans
were i flew from miami to buffalo they
picked me up
took me to their home let me take a
shower and change they made a big puerto
rican meal thought on his he told my
mother died and i like they made
gondolas the whole [ __ ] deal
then the father was a gambler
so he had a pass into this casino
so to go into this casino you kind of
went over the border
but they didn't really say nothing to
you as long as you got a sticker and you
were gonna go gamble
and that's what he would do he would
make believe like he'd go park we'd make
a u-turn he'd take me all the way to the
bus station and uh
the first city
there's a little city when you first get
over buffalo i forget what it's called
and i would take the bus to toronto and
then when i would come back i would go
through immigration and they would lose
their mind oh yeah they'd do a
background check and said when would you
get in here and i got in here last
thursday here's my documentation i did
the [ __ ] paperwork right i didn't do
the paperwork i had the paperwork from
the comedy club yeah and they lose their
mind you couldn't have gotten in here
what are you talking about anything i
[ __ ] got in here yeah i did that
about three times and then
one time before 9 11 they got me yeah
going in they said no you can't go in
there
and i went and got a hotel in detroit
like in the worst part of detroit
i probably had 300 on me
so i said i got no money for a hilton
so i said take me to the darkest part of
[ __ ]
i think i'm kidding you he took me
downtown he goes now the hotel's at 35
hours
i said perfect
and i got a [ __ ] this is oh my god
this is a [ __ ] up story and i [ __ ]
take the
the cab he puts me through this hulk but
on the way to the hotel i see coco's
comedy club
and i had a bunch of friends from
detroit that were out here that were all
comedy club cocoa guys i go oh my god
three blocks away
so i went up there the first night boom
i saw mimi gonzalez a little cuban
lesbian chick
and she goes i got no place to stay
[ __ ] i got two beds give me 17.50
i'm surprised you didn't get it for like
the whole 30. [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah she
gave me 17.50 like a [ __ ] she
took a shower the next day she went
somewhere i don't know what the [ __ ] she
what year was that
99
99 summer of 99 before montreal
man time has flown by it really has
can't believe it's 2017.
i can't believe it
it's it's freaking what'd you do two
thousand
two thousand yeah what'd you do two
thousand for new year's
two thousand let's see did you think the
martians were coming and [ __ ] uh well
the yankees won the world series i don't
know that yeah the subway series two
thousand
it must have been a decent year those
were those were good years for me back
then
those were better times i was going back
and forth l.a new york
and yankees mets that was good i flew
all the way from canada
to see the closing game i flew like five
hours and i drove five hours i was in
the in canada someplace called osoyos
doing some rinky dink movie i got off
and then i drove five hours to seattle
and dropped my kids off and then boom
and then flew five so i traveled like 10
hours for one game i said they better
[ __ ] clinch i didn't come this far to
lose
i'll [ __ ] kill them if they lose i'm
at shea stadium i'm going to celebrate
tonight and the yankees tough game but
they put them away we celebrated that
shay i love sticking it to the mets at
shea
it was a great feeling because i felt
like i willed them i said i came this
far not to lose there's no way i'm
[ __ ] losing like i'm playing i wasn't
playing but i'm taking it personal
and you know and the yankees did one
they pulled it out louis soho with a
little hit man you know what that sounds
like to me that sounds like when the red
sox came back uh three to one against
the yankees three-year-old
yeah
look at lee throwing soft in the woods
yeah
it's all right
and tell you remember two words bucky
dent he can revoke i could say a lot of
people because he could say boom
i gotta say 86 bill buck now
you're still you still got that [ __ ]
the red sox still got that baggage they
want a couple now the cubbies are off
the [ __ ] snide with the [ __ ] goat
they'll all go back into hibernation
soon the curse will come back it'll be
it'll re-fucking invent itself the
junkies have been cursed too they've
been cursed oh yeah the yankees are
cursed
they have a different curse
yeah they put them on oh yeah these did
they go i don't want to say but yeah
it's uh that new stadium is like the
kiss of death it really is you don't
knock down you don't you don't tear down
a shrine you see the red sox they don't
knock down fenway never the cubs
wouldn't tear it wrigley you don't do
that they moved across the street i
never felt the same i swear to god i
never felt the same
i don't i'm still [ __ ] angry i'm
really angry i that place is like an
impostor what what do you what do you
think about the ballparks out here nick
i hate them i don't think that i want at
least in southern california i don't
like them at dodger stadium i just think
it wasn't bad it's not bad it's set in
the canyons well yeah that is pretty
that i mean it is pretty that's true it
is pretty i remember when i first came
out here with my agent funny guy he was
taking me to dodger games like birdbank
high baby i was like what's burbank
that's where he went to high school he
was so excited to take me and dodge a
dog but the food sucks oh dodgy dogs oh
she wouldn't feed a dog a [ __ ] dog
you gotta get a new [ __ ] um you get
excited
and you always buy one to see if they
change you bite into them oh they're
former john furrier
it's terrible terrible terrible these
yankees
you know [ __ ] [ __ ] the food let
me tell you something i heard they got a
[ __ ] cheese steak a yankee stick oh
to die for that it's to [ __ ] die for
i have friends that go to the yankee
game yeah just to get the [ __ ]
cheesesteak is slamming
slamming it then you nathan's hot dog
great great hot dog they say you miss a
whole inning but it's worth the [ __ ]
weight but the best hot dog is the one
you have on the street and they call it
a sabret i got them at the house oh
they're great i got them you can have
the you can boil those in uh sauerkraut
and musk that's how you eat a hot dog
yeah yeah these people over here my kids
this one talking about [ __ ] ketchup
on a hot dog i said mustard is for the
hot dog yeah you ruined the whole
[ __ ] hot dog you gotta have a mustard
and sauerkraut
don't put no [ __ ] ketchup on that
gets me mad it gets me pissed i don't
hear that [ __ ]
that's some kind of ca i don't know what
the where that came from this guy puts
[ __ ] ketchup you put ketchup on the
door no no i put mustard but i can't put
my sometimes i'll do a plain because
every time i put mustard it just means
it's going on my shirt get the mustard
in the sauerkraut lee that's what makes
them i make them i get the sauerkraut i
put you you don't need to i've never
seen you with sauerkraut at the house oh
it's good
yeah
[ __ ] it overnight it's great and the
buns are a little a little stiff yeah to
see the steak i made the other night
that's why we need to get those things
that the guys carry around at the game
so you can steam the buns and all at the
same time you just want a simple hot dog
you know fenway park they got this bread
that's great it's like wonder bread
remember wonder bread back in the day it
was good bread
how is it now
still good it's still good peanut butter
and jelly whatever you noticed one the
bread is tremendous oh but these bread
today at last they've got all kinds of
preservatives and that's why the bread
lasts for a week it's weird they put and
don't buy bread at target because like
they take like six weeks old and [ __ ]
you get it oh no when you put the
[ __ ] when you put the peanut butter
on it it sticks to the [ __ ] thing and
the bread breaks what's better than
white bread with peanut butter if you're
hungry if you're starving
that's the [ __ ] sandwich right i had
to break that addiction
like i lost 10 pounds because i stopped
eating peanut butter
i love if there was peanut butter in my
house i would [ __ ] stick my finger in
it and just lick it i could get so high
at night i couldn't skippy so
i guess i got a big day oh you get the
bidet
in the shower
when i was a kid i was a creepy kid i
took it out and broke it i wish i had a
bidet
i like cleaning that ass
i didn't even know when i went to italy
you know i said i looked like oh what is
this [ __ ] i was a young guy she goes
that's to clean your ass
i didn't i never saw i didn't know what
i thought there was another toilet it
just took i should get one tushy.com i'm
always wiping wipe and wiping no this is
tremendous takes care of the hemorrhoids
cushy.com hello hello tushie.com i need
it it washes behind the nut sack you put
it on pot and it steams like a dry
cleaner you're like ah
that type of [ __ ] but steam comes out
really there's no germs then you dip the
helmet in there too oh while you're at
it you do a little agua mi daddy and i'm
saying
sometimes you need to put sometimes you
get a little puerto rican shower oh
that's the original puerto rican yeah
that's what a puerto rican shower is
these people out here think washing your
face and wetting your hands of puerto
rico
that's the byproduct of the puerto rican
shower right the original puerto rican
shower is washing that muffler wiping
the nut sack cleaning the helmet putting
some polish and shine taking that dead
piece smell off the helmet yeah but you
do it's a face cloth not i i read the
entire instruction booklet there's
nothing about the nut sack or anything
all that and where in the in the hello
because they have no imagination see
that's what i'm here for
i'm johnny imagination
you know what i'm saying you gotta have
imagination that's right you got water
sprinkling up it hits your [ __ ] and
it feels good so if it's hitting your
[ __ ] at a certain power okay what do
you think is gonna hit you what do you
think it's gonna feel like when it hits
your nut sack like that and all you
gotta do is just move back a quarter
inch that's it you'll feel it hitting
your nuts out and you move your feet you
make sure your hips are over your knees
you know what i'm saying yeah and you do
a little shake right there and it's all
over but the shot and then you move back
another inch use it all every day every
day in the middle of the day you got to
wash your muffin yeah i'm 298. you got
to clean that muffle you know what i'm
saying i like this
i like to start my day with it well no
why are you going to start your day with
if you're going to take a shower
right away if i'm going to work oh no no
when you work out in the morning you
wash your muffin yeah absolutely
i'm not mad at you yeah
you got to be fresh 2017. you got to
keep everything together yeah you ever
go to starbucks you stand in front of a
chick hot chick by the hair the back of
the head looks like a rat's nest
this dirty [ __ ] went out a [ __ ] smells
like a condom and she's standing online
waiting for a [ __ ] latte acting like
you guys you don't know nobody man
i can't stand dirty people clean up i
love washing three times a day i gotta
shower when i use it that [ __ ] about a
drought saved that for these [ __ ]
gentiles i take showers jack i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah i love the bathroom i
love the bathroom that's why i put my
robe on
that's why i focus in the shower i smoke
a tootsie roots yeah i get in that
[ __ ] shower i play scrubby dub dub i
let the fungi toenail get nice and sauce
i just got under it i'm overdue i looked
at that toe and it's stuffed with fungi
so tomorrow at the casino i'm going to
sit in that shower i'm bringing the
heavy duty nail clippers nice and i cut
them right in the shop you like the old
school soap or you like the liquid i
bring my own soap your own salt i bring
my own [ __ ] uh whatever you have a
favorite yeah the blue one blue one it
smells nice i take the drop cloth like
[ __ ] wash
i wash the muffin good i got a little
loose shampoo every day
[Music]
before they abandon [ __ ] i gotta let
them know i love them you can't be
walking around with dirty wait what are
you wearing on the uh uh under arm yeah
just unscented
oh you don't like it i like old schools
no no no no no spice oh spice makes you
smell like a billy goat dough nah when
you play the whole i don't put that on
does it matter no i've never seen it you
smell good just under here i put uh
whatever unscented the good stuff
unscented you use lotion
and do you explosion your body sometimes
i'm a lotion guy but i don't lotion my
stomach no i lotion my from the kneecap
down the foot yeah
that type of [ __ ] what about bats you
like bad stuff
what are you [ __ ] i'm just talking
about chevy breather i'm just
oh saying god i love the bedroom you
know you know what i like a bath but
when i have a bath i'm sitting there
thinking i don't know i like when it's a
bigger shower that i could sit on the
floor yeah what are the ones that have a
bench in it that you could sit down and
yeah but that means i got to sit where a
thousand other people put their [ __ ]
ass
like you built the bathroom i think i
always take like a little towel to put
my [ __ ] on so i don't know the fungus
and i sit on the floor and get the the
longest distance of the shower it steams
up mm-hmm i get the blackheads out steam
is the best it's the best you know
if you can put a steam
in your shower i i'd way better than the
sauna but the st there's nothing like
taking a steam
a sitting in a steam shower steam room i
love it i wish i could move into a place
like a building that has like that
there's a building in marina del rey
it's expensive
but there's everything there
oh yeah that would be great supermarket
the movie theater the taylor the baker
rouses
that's what i need man
is it a good deal to move in there i
don't know i think you got to buy the
condo and somebody's gotta die you gotta
go on a list really
i knew this guy
about [ __ ] 15 years ago i'm at the
laugh factory one night and this guy
comes up to me
he's got to be 60 years old
he says my name is mike i'm from the
bronx
you killed me tonight he goes nobody
else laughed i was the only guy howling
because i got every word you said
i got how long you been out he said 30
years i go over 35 what have you been
doing
he goes you have another show running
into the steel like oh yeah he goes i'm
the creator wow because i'm out here
tonight i was looking for a different
girl for a show but it's really nice to
meet you
who's your agent i told my agent
he goes i'm going to be in touch with
you man he goes you know anything about
bookmaking what you were talking about
oh yeah
contacted me six months later he did he
would take me out to lunch in hollywood
and we'd talk about bookmaking and he'd
take notes from me and stuff
and then one day he invited me to his
home he goes do you want to come down
marina del rey and right a little with
me and i went all the way down there and
uh yeah
unfucking believable you pull up valet
parking is it called the bella fontaine
something like that and it's huge
[ __ ] it looks like a stadium you found
it lee though
the one bed started 24 35 and three beds
are 41 30. 41.31
a month
how much
hundred and 4
dollars for how many bedrooms three
that's not bad
and how is it and what do they got they
got everything there right
uh it says they have uh
explore the marina marketplace and all
the local favorites such as gelson's
market where we have the convenience
every doorstep without the bus of the
city
everything they got everything down
there it's it's uh so i went down there
a couple times right
cool dude he we went and pitched we
couldn't sell it you know it was just a
little too edgy there was no internet
then there was nothing then you know
right we went to the usa we went to fx
fx16 whatever that is fx18
we went to a couple places and but he
still kept in touch with me but the
other thing i didn't know
was that he was writing all those movies
at lifetime
all those years
excuse me those are the weirdest
scripts because in those days somebody
signs with lifetime and you just keep
writing movies from
so he was dick van dyke
all right his dick van dyke and his son
so
you know i'm moving around my business
and also i get a call and it's mike and
he goes doug
i got work for you three days on the
movie you're playing a bookie he goes i
wrote the role in it's a dick van dyke
movie they're gonna bust you him in the
sun
so he wrote me into this movie he knew i
was a dick van dyke fan you know he got
me on this set for three days that's
nice they play this company was very
interesting
they shot a movie every eight
weeks
they took a week off
and they started the movie it was like
one of those like b movies maybe it was
all lifetime okay yeah okay they just
shut up all lifetime this has to be
2002 2003.
i was talking to the guy and i'll tell
you they paid they told you in the
beginning listen
if you want to do this you could do this
if you don't we pay scale
listen we've had
everybody do this
so don't give me your song and dance
everybody did these things like the one
i did had [ __ ] people in it like i
forget who was i didn't give a [ __ ]
because it had dick van dyke right and
he was cool as [ __ ] and his father and
his son his son not his father but you
know what these people did that i never
forgot about them i worked three days
and all three days
there was a basket
a present
all three days nice had a bottle of
champagne nice it cost to make dollars
did you get treated you understand me i
never ever forgot these guys in fact we
shot at a bar and they go we're just
gonna take over the bar and drink and
one of the guys was smoking dope the
director was smoking dope and like you
guys smoke pot with dick van dyke around
he goes he's a hey guy he don't give a
[ __ ] about
weed so right that's but they shot a
movie lee
every eight weeks one week off were they
running them too
probably so this they were just a
machine what was it
they probably had it down on the side
they had it down to a science yeah were
they were they like the it was like kind
of like dick wolf did specials they did
lifetime movies right oh they probably
made it so they were just right for nick
tutura so it would be nick's got a sixth
movie deal a six picture deal so nick's
gonna do three this year and three next
year but we also have to check from
the check that from cbs uh they had her
at the time
so it's hurt so you would basically work
for eight weeks
then you'd have nine weeks off
you would work eight weeks then you'd
have nine weeks off that was the
rotation right pretty [ __ ] cool yeah
and i talked to the guys and i was like
dog we just come back and blasted no
overtime by the way
seven to five yeah
no overtime they didn't eat overtime no
they were so good no overtime
quick looks these people are smart yeah
quick looks quick they were two they
framed two ahead
they were like a soap opera type [ __ ]
angle i was surprised into eight million
of them that sounds like you're you know
one man he got me one and then he
offered me one day and another one like
a year later did he give you a good one
like a good the bookie one was good i
still got the real yeah i weighed it did
they pay that
they must have paid the top star or
something
i the company it was really weird
because he was saying you know this
company this is what they do because
like years ago man you know when i was
first on nypd blue
i got like a movie at a week i remember
i couldn't believe like an offer came in
it was like and i i i basically turned
it down because i was gonna do a play it
was a lot of money
and then i was i was saying oh man i
[ __ ] up why did i do that and then
what then they went to matthew perry and
then he didn't want to do it so i was
able to get it back
i was like man i was almost going to
blow
you know
125 000 or something to start like a
movie of the week but you could make
some nice coin in your in your hiatus
back then if you were on tv you had a tv
name so by the way you were you know uh
a commodity you know but you can't you
can't find that [ __ ] today don't matter
who you are and you know they bring them
they don't do the movie of the weeks and
all that [ __ ] i don't know no nobody's
doing that get away with those things
you know i mean now you got to go and
fight for guest spots
guest spot guess what
well he's going through changes i just
caught him it's the beginning stages is
he yeah what's going on with him you
could just look over and you can see him
like he gets very sad he thinks that he
thinks that jerusalem and
he thinks of the old country
he gets all sad and [ __ ]
someone stole my credit card and tried
to buy jamaican food so it was a bad
night when was that what was this last
night
38 of jamaican food oh really i don't
know then they knew it wasn't me they
did yeah they knew i wasn't eating
jamaican food so i'm sure at least my
credit card companies i mean listen
listen that's all right let's pretend
let's pretend that the
they caught it and also they go all
right type up lisa picture you came up
with that shirt i'm looking like you do
right now and they said let me ask you a
question does this guy look like he gets
jamaican food
what do you think the question no he
gets good food i can tell he knows what
he likes
and he's never been to a jamaican
restaurant before
in new york [ __ ] all this this [ __ ]
that wine
with the edible [ __ ] makes this feel
like mushrooms yeah yeah
i like it it's a little pinot i like it
it's very nice yeah did you finish your
wine absolutely cheese i like peanut
butter
sure when do you drink wine i never i
don't want to drink i hate i don't but
when i do i like pinot noir let me ask
you something how many tutorials are
there in the acting business
there's my brother
um there's aida my cousin me
and uh
yeah my my son and my daughter you know
interested but she's more interested but
she's interested in more music but uh
there's three of us that i know of she
had another sister who was talented aida
but she didn't
she didn't really make a living at it
she was a
musical theater girl but uh
as far as i know the the three of us
yeah
you weren't one of those acting class
dudes no
no you didn't get down to that to the
south village and then like with monaco
no i was a freaking theater major for
one year running around in tights and i
didn't like it and all the kids i
thought they were all kind of you know
fanuc you know so i was like the same
for me i i i gotta put tights on and
stretch and i was making noises in the
class and
one of my friends who liked this one guy
liked me none of those people made it
it's so funny
you know and i did it one year there and
vocal me me me me me me mao
like my brother does
all that [ __ ] i'm like i just didn't i i
it not that i didn't want to act i just
didn't like all that theatrical theater
kids so i you know after one year i said
i'm i'm not coming back this is not this
is not what i thought you know acting
was but i think i wasn't that's i wasn't
totally committed then when i got
committed later on i learned on the job
you know i didn't have all the classical
i took a class with this guy bob modica
but him i liked because he wasn't like
your typical acting teachers like if my
father became an acting teacher
he was a bit insane yet he's the stars
coffee with a switchblade
and you would have to do this exercise
called the repetition
and he would speak like this and you
basically have to put your attention on
somebody they put their attention on you
and you have to be honest so you might
say like well they might say like
you're angry you know you have to be
truthful i'm angry yes you're angry yes
i'm angry
you're angry right i'm angry
yes you're angry yes i'm angry
that bothers you yes it bothers me it
bothers you yes it bothers me it bothers
you yes it bothers you
it was you had to stay in the moment but
if you were fake modica would be like
that's not it
he would stop the exercise but sometimes
like
if you didn't know what to say he would
write on a piece of paper now where was
this at this was in carnegie hall he was
great this guy how much a month robin
back then
um
it might have been like it was kind of
big you know it was expensive back then
maybe 150 a month or 200 i don't
remember but he took a liking to me you
know because he knew i was kind of like
raw and i was like a caveman
because he didn't remember he talked to
mike because my brother studied with him
a little bit and he played football
against him and his brother against my
uncle tony it's so weird that we found
this guy modica
he actually was almost in the godfather
he was almost sonny corleone because of
coppola i spoke to kopla he said he
loved bob modica this guy he had a
little acting career but he really
teaching was his thing but i loved him
because it was like my father who
he was forceful but educated
like you know i tell you sometimes to go
outside it was like an idea and say go
outside and take a walk
and
figure out why you're coming to the door
don't come until you know
right so one time i [ __ ] like
disappeared for 15 minutes he came
looking for me he goes you got to come
back
and i said i know bob because no no you
got to come back he liked me
because you know he was like i told my
brother i don't know what that kid wants
to do but
he's interesting nice to come in with my
daughter man uniform he'd be like hey
general
there was a doorman around the corner
you go you did you just in the
neighborhood
you figured just stop by
because you have to try to get in when
people were working you had to listen
the door was a block that said robert x
motoka it was kind of a scary door
and he's over there with the switchblade
and [ __ ] moving the desk around he
was a great guy he was actually in a
movie with me federal hill he played
like my dad i gave him a bath it was
weird working with him because then i
became an actor and i was like giving
him
but he but in the classroom
he was great i mean you know like i say
i but i
i more or less learned on the job
i wasn't
classically trained like you know my
brother and all that hoyt it wasn't my
thing i don't knock it i think it's
great
if i had to do it over maybe i would do
all that
all that [ __ ] you know and work on my
body and learn how to stretch that's why
my brother my brother you know he slays
on the ground he stretches and when you
hear him do his [ __ ] vocal warm up
[Music]
me
that sounds crazy i go what are you
doing john
so i'm warming up
warming up my voice nick
you know i'm like okay
i did a play with him one time he was in
the theater doing all those noises and
he goes
just come come stretch with me
come stretch with me oh he's very funny
you know i did this whole epidural thing
because i have two bulging discs so i
couldn't walk a couple weeks ago so he
goes i said i'm having side effects and
he goes
that's why you shouldn't do uh the
needles and i said john
john i can't walk you understand
that's a different story
but uh you know but it's funny when i'll
say something he repeats it back and
i'll say something he repeats it back i
tried to tell him about my cataract do i
had a cataract surgery so what kind of
surgery was it
was it a cataract wasn't it you know it
sounds like insane we say goodbye to
each other like this all right nick i'll
see you all right i love you all right
take it easy bye bye john bye bye
goodbye
all right good hearing your voice love
you we say goodbye for like five minutes
saying goodbye
all right bye-bye did you grew up close
to aida
no you know aida was in manhattan her
father was an artist she grew up very
different than us
she grew up more like bohemian
because my uncle my father's brother was
a crazy artist talented guy very smart
but all the other brothers were in
construction so we grew up in the
suburbs she actually grew up like in
manhattan in a synagogue she had a way
different upbringing than me so is that
why she was so good in the sopranos
because it was her
yeah she's wild you know i wrote a
little something that we're going to do
this month
and she is
she is freaking wild i mean she's
talented but she makes me look like i'm
normal her add is
she's off the wall when she gets going
you know um so i gotta i've never really
worked with her i gotta my brother said
just make sure your hands are up keep
your hands up
he loves her i love her too but uh she's
she's definitely she's uh she's out
there you have to meet her she's like
she's like you toward the force
big presence comes in the room tears you
up she'll tear you apart
you know she tells you i mean she sounds
delightful i remember when i was
auditioning for this but she is she is i
mean in an affectionate way when i was
auditioning for the sopranos
that was the big
search at that time
it wasn't that they were looking for
characters as much for a woman to play
tony's sister oh yeah he was a had a big
to do with her he loved her they did a
play on broadway together
and i think he fell in love with her and
i heard he was a mensch of a guy he
helped a lot of people he helped a lot
of people gave people money helped the
cast get more you don't find guys like
that on television shows so she loved
james and uh and james loved her i think
he fought for her he fought for her to
get the part
but uh
you know they were great together they
were great together i mean that was
iconic
that is like that that stuff that
sopranos
i never seen anything like that
and i go through phases where i will not
put it on
and then i'll put it on every night for
a month like this was the first holiday
that i didn't put it on like i usually
put i'll go crazy i'll do two seasons
and three nights wow you know the
carmella parts i'll speed through them
she's good she's good but it's not
necessary but he's the guy that drives
yeah i miss him you [ __ ] he's one guy
he was at my mother's funeral and i tell
you john directed him in the movie and
you could tell he was a special guy he
had a
he had a big soul that guy you could
tell he saw this one movie and i broke
down crying he goes
it was about my family and he actually
played like my dad and
yeah i didn't know him that well because
that that movie affected you i said yeah
he had no [ __ ] idea how it affected
me but you could tell he was he was a
deep guy dark guy and deep guy but
people loved him i mean
it's a shame that he
passed so young
man was a shame because so talented too
but uh yeah she i mean you know she's
great i mean she's a it's gonna be fun
to work with her i haven't
i will see how it's gonna i've never
really like done anything with her so
this is kind of funny she was texting me
today like i need to talk to you i need
to know
i'm like i'm playing it cool i'm like
all right we'll talk we'll talk so i
wrote something for her
you know but i i i mean i think she
should be doing much more she's very
funny too
they don't know how to use her you know
this industry like they don't know how
to use people what has she been doing
since the surprise she's been doing
little guest spots this that but she's
so much i saw her on this brooklyn
nine-nine and she's like she's great and
then they chop it up you know sometimes
you do a tv show they just chop you they
chop it up it's so choppy i was helping
her memorize her lines at home because
she's like a little slow she likes to
write her lines out and
i just i work i work faster because i'm
just i'm that's how i worked in
television
you know i always learned how to work
fast with tv
but um but she's got her own you know
for auditions now nick it's a complete
different game awesome and it's so weird
i don't even know how to audition
anymore i don't even know how to
audition anymore like now
this last one i went in for i prepared
so much for it on my own i went over
over over wrote it out
wrote it out went to sleep got up at
four went over it again after we dropped
mercy off me and my wife went over over
over over over over
and it's like uh
i'm not disenchanted
i just know that even though you go in
they already got somebody in mind i'm
very nice that you brought me in thank
you very much
but i'm not even in the [ __ ] game
anymore that's fine i mean i'm not
i'm not disappointed as much as i
thought i would be you know
but no no i forgot how to do it and that
was my favorite part of it
my thing was doing the work that's why i
got pissed off was now i gotta go to
wardrobe course an audition is not
[ __ ] nice it's not it's not a
performance it's an audition some guys
are good at it some may be better than
that because that's that's my thing
yeah i mean there are times that i love
it and then there are other times i just
feel like i'm all you know sometimes i'm
if i'm not there i just sometimes go and
then sometimes when i'm there i really
come out of there feeling like wow i did
something you know you know when you did
something good and then you know when
you're off sometimes you're just off and
sometimes you're on but i i never
think that that's like you know the
final
you know that's why i like look at it as
if you really want someone
that's not to tell all you know i've not
been that lucky with auditions in my
life i've gotten some
i've gotten some you know
i mean i actually and white was a young
young guy nypd blue i only read for them
i never went to i didn't have to go
through that network that's horrible if
you ever have to test and you have to go
you know to the studio
nightmare that's nervous breakdown
that's what i was doing
no i've seen guys that did and and i was
with guys when i had my own pilot at cbs
guys i brought in like somebody like
billy gardell i was trying to get him
hired as my brother everybody goes he
don't look like your brother
i said yeah but maybe he's adopted i was
like fighting for him i was you know and
i remember you know in front of them
coming to the network and then you hear
what people say stu it's terrible
you know and i'm like because i've been
on you know you've been on the other
side
i knew what that was like but that's why
i always like it gave my all
with other actors when i was the few
times that i ever was like on that side
of the fence it was interesting to see a
lot of guys that come in you know there
were famous guys too they were like hey
i read for you
i said yeah i know they said you know
you didn't hire me i was like one time
one of the baldwin brothers said that to
me i was like oh well i didn't you know
the guy was being a bit of a jerk so i
let it go
you know i auditions is it's a weird
thing it's a weird thing it's amazing
how good
i got at them nick
how i would take rooms
and [ __ ] demolish them that's four or
five people in the room
i would [ __ ] the
the peter siegel audition for the
longest yard was a very blase audition
yeah it was till this day i don't know
how i got it because the read was hard
oh it was hard i had sent the tape in
and
read with him i think my audition was
was okay it was i mean i didn't know
what it was gonna be i don't i had no
idea what that part was gonna become the
the beauty of that part and brucey is it
became on paper it was nothing
and sandler added so many things for me
that 95 percent of it made the movie but
really on paper brucy was
was really not not a big deal and it
became a beautiful part but i i got to
give adam because adam was like he fed
me the ball have to toro say that
happened he didn't know me that well but
i went in there with an idea
my brother told me that he goes if he
sees you're funny
you know he'll pick up on that just go
in there with something and that's why i
went in blazing with the haircut that
this that i i didn't really know what i
was gonna do
but it became a great part and it was
nothing on paper what was your first big
audition
first big audition
um
like in front of it like beside the
spike lee movies yeah like in new york i
went like uh for my cousin vinnie really
i was up for that i didn't get it
obviously but who was the casting
director do you remember
i forget it might have been it might
have been a big one like
lynn something i forget his name he was
actually a big now who else was up for
that role when you went down to the
wreath who else did you say i i don't
remember
you know
who i saw or anything like that i just
know that i was
i was pretty i was almost in this movie
alive uh frank marshall movie it was a
big audition they liked me a lot this
that movie where they all eat each other
on the plane the the team
so i was almost i had a big scar on my
head i remember i got banged my head
five o'clock in the morning i had this
big score when i went in for that movie
alive and i came close and i was close
on an oliver stone movie i was a young
guy he said oliver liked you he never
picked up his head
born on the fourth of july there were
like big movies that i was like i was
being like you know i no know who i was
but that was a good sign that was a good
sign that people like they like you they
like you you like you aurora is a button
but they [ __ ] like you and then i
nailed the pilot the year before nypd
blue
and with with thomas they called me on
the door
i was like and the guy goes you got to
get on the plane baby i didn't like that
i don't want
tomorrow morning you get a test i came
out to l.a man i was walking around this
[ __ ] sunset boulevard with a powder
blue leisure suit this is what i went to
the cbs jeff seganski was the president
and i went in front of cbs with a powder
blue leisure suit peter dobson was the
star he had a lot of pilots back there
yeah
and i had a hat on my head and went back
to my agents after the [ __ ]
um i remember i was going up against
this other guy from chicago and the guy
was a nice guy he goes uh you're gonna
get the part not me i said i don't know
i don't know [ __ ] and then my agent goes
well they said the guy said you look
like the lead guy and i went crazy i
said what i don't look anything like
that [ __ ] guy you're not gonna give
it to me because i look like that guy
the guy called the agency peter dobson
he liked me he said don't worry don't
worry you're gonna get it
just go back home let them bring in guys
with blonde hair and blue eyes you watch
you're gonna get this pilot
i was so [ __ ] angry i don't look
nothing like you peter he goes i know i
know
i was so pissed man
i [ __ ] went home i sweated it out the
way it's like amazing so peter dobson
was deleted he was the lead he read with
me in front of the network some guy
named jeff seganski
the president
the president goes he looks like him
and so and when i went back to the
president i know i said i don't look
nothing like the [ __ ]
pete i don't look like you he goes i
know
just say yes to him and shake his hand
so [ __ ] funny and then they casted me
with mitchell whitfield who was in who
was the other guy who was in my cousin
vinnie
and and the funniest thing happened to
me in l.a we were at the formosa cafe
with peter dobson
and
i'm [ __ ] really naive and he goes hey
jody foster's there
and my brother knew jody foster i don't
know i was gonna i was gonna go up to
her
and they go you know jody's a dyke or
something like that
no this is a true story
so i'm on the telephone talking them i
don't know if it was my brother or
somebody i go yeah i met jodie jodie
foster jody the dyke
i yell it loud the table is she's right
there
she [ __ ] like a piece of bread or a
napkin like
threw it at me these guys were peeing in
their pants
she didn't i had to tell my brother yeah
call jodie foster like i didn't know she
was right there to go did she throw it
at me mean and then she was and they
were like no she truly like giggling
like what's wrong with you
so you know the next day in the studio
they were like oh jody the dyke is
looking for you to like they wouldn't
stop wouldn't let me live it down but my
god they put me at the mondrian hotel i
was living the dream i had a pilot
better days i wore a turban in one scene
and the show didn't get picked up i
remember in the spring when i get picked
up i was like oh [ __ ] there goes my
career
and then a year later
i uh i uh i was up for [ __ ] nypd blue
but then they were like you know is he
mexican is he this he's here i said i
you know i could be as a puerto rican
tell them a little puerto rican because
they liked me but they said does he have
any hispanic blood you know and i was
like yeah i got it somewhere in my ass i
don't know don't [ __ ] take it away
from me because i'm not puerto rican i'm
new york i'm new york this is a new york
show
so they kept me on a [ __ ] string for
like a few months
and my agent was like don't worry baby
you're gonna get it honey you're gonna
get it and i didn't know i was like are
you sure i'm gonna get it i had a
nervous break now i had to take a leave
of absence when i was a doorman because
i got let me ask you questions that's
sick this morning
who believe
this agent
marty lee sack he's a big agent okay but
he used to talk like that hey honey what
the [ __ ] are you doing we had a great
relationship you've [ __ ] what
happened to the dude who stole the check
the check oh that guy no he's a criminal
the sixth grand
oh oh that guy with the bulging eyes no
marty's big shot body went to caa
that guy was a criminal why i ever let
that guy in my in my life
tells you how stupid and dumb and crazy
i am because people said i had a guy who
came over my house when the bulging eye
guy was hanging around
and he said nick is that guy with you
and i said yeah
they said you can't have a guy
crazier than you represent you can be
crazy because you're an artist this
guy's out of his [ __ ] mind and i
didn't know he was a criminal
he stole the money and then gave me a
check that bounced after he [ __ ]
stole the money then i told him i said
you're you're [ __ ] dead
not only did you steal the money i
caught you
and now you give me a check that bounced
on top of it
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] the big bulging i'm
doing world trade center he's behind
nick cage and everybody and nick cage
goes does he represent you and your
brother
i was like no nick he's a little wacky
guys i got to get rid of this guy i got
to get him out of my life i had a great
agent i had a great agent was a uta so
you didn't get him out of your life you
gotta i did but he got [ __ ] he was
embezzling money or yeah he went to jail
he used to call me from jail i said
don't call me no more i don't want to
i don't want to hear this [ __ ] what time
do they do i take him to a [ __ ]
meeting i tell him shut the [ __ ] up in
the room don't open your mouth
because at one time i was at an hbo
meeting
i'm pitching something my brother's on
the phone his mouth almost opened my
brother said who was in that room
i said some [ __ ] wacky bandages don't
don't bring that guy don't bring that
guy in the room i said yeah i know i
know because i tell him shut the [ __ ] up
i said no shut the [ __ ] up
keep your mouth shut
they're here to meet me this isn't this
is a meeting about you know i'm about
talent you don't know you're gonna
[ __ ] say stupid [ __ ] you look like
johnny gombots with bulging eyes dressed
apart you're supposed to be a manager
oh what i could write a movie about this
[ __ ] guy
and his name is one of the names on
seinfeld that's the hilarious thing it's
one of the characters on simon that's
his [ __ ] name say something when he
used to come to the center of the
longest yard you remember him yeah
i saw him afterward i went somewhere
he didn't get me that job i gave he
didn't get me to jail here's the funny
thing i went somewhere
and somebody i knew
got up from a table
and came over and said hello to me i
gave him a hug right and where he went
back to sit that dude was there
so immediately
he came over and he says hello he used
to stick out like a sore thumb yeah yeah
yeah i met him in church years ago i
didn't know
yeah this is where i [ __ ] met him in
church
and and and you know
i had my suspicion about him it but i
was always like you know always like
street guys i had this stupid way about
me like i was established with uta with
legitimate [ __ ] people not johnny
gambach with bulging eyes who are there
other clients who him yeah who is that
i was his biggest client
and and he would drop my name but you
look bad if you go nick is with him that
doesn't look good for nick
nick's got to be with somebody that when
i had marty had good people you know i
walk in the room with wb i got a deal
cbs i got a deal can't bring this
lunatic into a [ __ ] meeting with cbs
they're going to go why are you with
this man i got to put a cork in his
mouth
because he just would sound like a
buffoon he dressed like a i didn't i'd
yell at him he'd go you're always saying
try to hurt my feelings yeah i rob it
shut the [ __ ] up
shut up when you go in the room
at the part
play your part
don't open your mouth don't get in my
way it's not about you
i'm here i was a good pitcher back then
i knew how to [ __ ] pitch
and then a a maniac like this you could
[ __ ] me up just look at him lee's going
through change all right i don't think i
want to be a manager anymore why not
i know let me tell you that guy
my hair rises you know you see it i see
it
ah
you say when i see it you know it yes
you know it right off the bat i should
have known better i'm really that was a
really everybody in my life told me why
are you with him
and but he was a hustler and he would
you know and i was at a time i got like
you know i'm not getting the attention
this that but you don't opt that way you
don't go from the major leagues to like
some [ __ ] you know international
[ __ ] league playing with this guy
because it looked he looked bad
you know so i thought i figured let me
give him a chance and then i started
going to other agents but he was always
he was just a disaster this guy to have
him
you know represent you just look bad for
you sounds like bill murray and what
about bob he just like kept following
you even after you had to see his
eyeballs he had a cd i don't know
the [ __ ] eyes you could tell he was
he's bugged out he is [ __ ] i don't
know if he was doing drugs i don't know
i know figure out if he was doing drugs
he still calls me you know anybody and
i'm like oh my god because
he had to pay restitution yeah he paid
restitution he's in vegas now some
what's he doing i don't know what the
[ __ ] he does god bless him i don't wish
him any harm he's not no no no not a bad
guy don't just just keep going
i was one of those guys so i know
exactly how you know but i always you
know
i always liked i had an attraction to
street guys this that i was like
lunatics but this is business
you can't have a lunatic on your team
when you try if you're a little wild in
a room that's different you're artistic
you're creative they understand that
but you have your business guy who's a
wackadoo
that don't look good you're like well
why is he that doesn't fit why are they
together and i used to get some weird
you know i used to try to cover it up
and play it off like yeah yeah he's he's
okay he's uh he hustles you he's not a
bad guy he means well you know right and
that's about it take him on the side
just just
don't say no don't open up that's the
eyeballs that that really got
you know he's a character that if i ever
write that character you know into
something fantastic let me tell you
something fantastic way before we had to
be
it's 2007
this had to be
2002
i was stuckly i didn't know what the
[ __ ] to do
and i met this dude this dude hit me up
on the hot mail
he's a record producer he's working with
all these people
but he wants to switch into comedy
comedy's making a comeback brother
let's do this comedy thing man i'm gonna
tape your first cd type special i got
contacts and hbo and
i was like okay i met him a few times
never asked me for money or nothing this
went on for about six months
i'm looking at this guy one day bro
he had no [ __ ] teeth
holy [ __ ] he had like cracked teeth how
many days did it take you to realize
that i don't want to look at people man
i would look at his eyes you know what
i'm saying i wouldn't literally look at
his [ __ ] mouth
he had all rotten [ __ ] teeth and he's
telling me that he was a record producer
but now i'm thinking i'm like oh boy i
made a mistake all right he gets me a
spot there used to be a club downtown i
don't know what happened to it
they moved like ten times they were just
[ __ ] thieves these people
i did a show down there when that i did
tom lycus
yeah i'm like man at the time i nobody
knew who joe diaz was nobody knew who i
was but there was 40 50 people there
this guy comes over at the end of the
night gives me like 35 hours like are
you [ __ ] kidding me that's laying
into the fight with ernie g
it was just a horrible [ __ ] night but
in the meantime this guy was supposed to
take
both shows
he had people there he had brothers
there look at dogs i'm going out of
pocket for you man
this one you're gonna be the first
artist on my label
and he he had wires and microphones a
week went by two weeks went by he
finally called me back
he goes can i buy you lunch tomorrow
so the next day he tells me man i don't
know how to tell you this
something happened in that bar
the temperature just zapped the
recording
what happened
the record i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened they didn't tape it they didn't
even tape it there was nothing they
weren't taping it visually they were
taping it
audio you know like for a cd type thing
no yeah but there was
listen you you know and i should have
known i mean
you know i i i don't know what happened
to me i was
at the time i think i was a little
frustrated a couple of pilots that
almost got on the air
and my agent had he had big big clients
do it big tv guys drew carey all
but he was great we were you know we had
a great and i don't know i just was like
all right i'll give this guy a shot but
you know you let someone like that in
your life
you know
you know it's you don't let people like
that
you don't let people in like that this
is business
they could screw you up
because you know who you're with is a
reflection on you
so you know you walk in the room with
this guy
johnny gombotz from you know he thinks
he's johnny gombach but he's really like
a character of himself
it was just bad you know i was telling
lee
before you came we're talking about
managers and agents
and i was telling lee about when i first
moved he had a manager
and he was the only guy
that he sat me down and he goes listen
your comedy career is not going to blow
up
he goes i can't sell you except the
three people in this town like you one
of his mitsy short
because i think you should start going
in for this character real nick this guy
would send me in auditions those days
i couldn't handle i'd fall apart in the
seams
men in black i went in for a bunch of
big movies
it's hard in the early days you know go
in there and see actors i'd [ __ ] my
pants yeah but you know what he got me
chops and he had a plan and his plan
worked and you know what years ago
when i was trying to really work hard at
comedy a couple years ago this is the
most look i am i would look at comedy
clubs
and if certain comics worked at that
comedy club i wouldn't work there
there's times that mid-level managers
have approached me
that are pretty decent but i don't want
to be with the people in their lineup
they might have a comedian i don't want
to be next to that lineup i don't want
him name
his name and my name mentioned in the
same circle right you have to look at
all those things what are you saying
yeah
so
why is a uh an audition for like a big
like men in black movie different i know
like the location is different maybe i
mean is that it like the location of the
people you're doing it for like
why is that okay okay so let's say i go
to uh uh not hollywood gawa
let's say i go
in for a mid-level movie i'll go on
somewhere on sunset when i booked uh 18
wheels of justice it was a place across
the street from the strip club what's
the strip club on sunset there
that that almost burnt down the jews
burnt it down on christmas three years
ago during hanukkah so they could have
it out it was hanukkah we wouldn't burn
nothing down
we let the candles on
what's that on sunset strip close to the
comedy store
seventh film
is it the seventh family the bar no no
no body shop it's the body shop
yeah this place was a little buildingly
and you went in there you you took an
elevator up to the third floor and you
sat in the hallway you signed your name
and you went there now
forget that shitley forget it forget
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you gotta drive on to
sony studios
down there whatever the [ __ ] it is
you gotta drive on you get out of your
car you got the sides you got your
headshot it's a beautiful day to be
alive you're breathing [ __ ] oxygen on
the walk there you see shows that are
taping you're just in a different
environment you have no [ __ ] idea
okay sometimes you go to sony and you
walk past adam sandler's office and you
keep walking whatever
you know what from the minute you walk
in there your [ __ ] adrenaline's
pumping now you go up you sign your name
you've studied this audition for 12
[ __ ] hours you know it inside out you
don't have to put your [ __ ] glasses
on that's killing me you got to put your
glasses on mid-breathe you know you have
to know those lines and you have to
prepare that audition already for the
second call back
so when i go in in those days if i went
in there for the first time
that would be the first [ __ ] read
so think about that lee here you are
walking on a [ __ ] studio where films
are shut i could because there's good
students in bad studios well no no no
you're in a [ __ ] studio where films
are shot
for a guy like me that was never gonna
happen
that don't happen for a lot of people
just to walk in the studio freely to go
all the way down there i remember going
in for nypd blue
at fox and walking all the way to the
boston [ __ ] building
but here's the beauty of
walking slow kind of depressed and i
blew the audition mm-hmm and this lady
comes out and she goes are you here for
the audition and i go yeah
and she goes read these lines and the
movie was basketball and i got
six weeks on the [ __ ] movie really on
the fox slide on the walk out of ny
blue that building was a cool building
was tremendous oh that was it was great
stephen's building but you had a walk
there you got to walk down you got to
walk down and it was eight [ __ ] miles
when it's 80 degrees and you got black
leather on because you're playing johnny
bananas yeah you got a black velour
warm-up suit on and you weigh 350. it's
hot and you're sweating the coke and the
weed and the chinese food out of
yourself did you read for the producers
uh
okay so i went in for nypd blue
and they liked me the first time
and right away a week a week later they
called in
for something else for if i would read
for a janitor or something
and i went in for a janitor
and i didn't get it i wasn't spanish
enough
all right
they wanted they got to be puerto rican
or dominican i'm cuban dog it's a
different spanish i didn't get it and
then
i didn't hear from them for like a month
and i got a call one day jeff getlin
calls me goes listen
i got a big [ __ ] audition for you
tomorrow do you have a coach and i go
[ __ ] yeah he goes well get this
jeff getlin loved those latin auditions
and at the time i was already starting
to hate him i could see that i couldn't
sell
they would say thank you for coming in
and when i did go to producers
the producers would always go are you
even spanish right and i'm saying i go
god damn it
god damn it yeah because i think you
might be italian you might be yeah yeah
not a guy so i get this thing and it's a
a [ __ ] colombian drug dealer god damn
it
and it's a good one it's like i don't
know what the [ __ ] it was it was like
nine pages or something wow
i go in there danny trejo's there a
bunch of other spanish dudes are there i
[ __ ] my pants when i see danny trail
he's in heat yeah one of my chances he's
in heat yeah i've done a [ __ ] nothing
i do spots at the comedy store i went in
there and just fell apart well i'm not
trying to be rude but
would you and danny trejo go off of the
same role they would look at everybody
for every spanish spanish people okay
look at a lot of people and danny got it
really a warm-up suit he wore the
warm-up suit i think i might go back i
might have been here yeah i was there
yeah
seven ninety-eight you finally went on i
wasn't there no no i went on years later
but i did so bad at that nine page
audition
he didn't call me in again i went to
acting class at ivana chubby and i told
the coach can i go to bathroom yeah and
he told me
write him a letter and i wrote him a
letter and
they brought me into something i booked
it let me do the shout outs go ahead all
right buddy
go to the bathroom over here i gotta do
shout outs anyway
run run
i gotta do the original shout out right
here for my boys down and middling
[ __ ] texas
to isaac at the boys
mike duffy loves you guys
take care of that [ __ ]
also the uh smiles panero
martial arts chat dom de niro my main
man matt balkasar
space monkey sean
jacob cabillo lorne rosenka my brother
there he is chris miller
and the dead squad [ __ ] family
happy 2017.
what's going on there taizen how you
feeling over there i'm feeling really
good to have you around kaluka casino
was sold out
it's a small room but cleveland uncle
joey's coming i'm coming for steep mayo
chick it's over
i said it correctly i know you can't do
that ever again i can't sue it over
again no no no it's weird i don't like
it
i'll be there next thursday
friday and [ __ ] saturday ready to
rock [ __ ]
[Music]
what's going on with you brother
i'm doing really good but i could tell
you're going through changes right now
i'm going to change but i really feel
like you missed your
your calling as the member of a cuban
traveling banned i feel like that was
must have been the life
we were watching those videos before it
blew my mind and i just
like i could do the cowbell and like
travel the world
like that just seemed like you were born
to do it well you keep talking that
nonsense i'm not going to give you
edibles no more
[ __ ] people they eat this weed and
also they get all [ __ ] psychological
on me so let me talk to you about
something
i'm 53 years old
i went to new york city
it was until i went to new jersey
where i met italian people
i must have gone to italian restaurants
as a kid
but once i got the real [ __ ] taste
when i went to jersey
i think i first discovered italian food
at catholic church
sister angela and stuff like that would
make the [ __ ] lasagna but that wasn't
none
until i moved to north bergen bro
and i fell in love with it
it took me away from cuban food it took
me away from cheeseburgers
to me i i had always eaten spaghetti
with meat sauce i had never seen
spaghetti with sausage
meatballs and [ __ ] regard cheese and
crushed pepper and the cheese and
i had never seen that [ __ ] before it
blew my [ __ ] circuitry
so for [ __ ] 40 years
everybody tells me about their [ __ ]
you gotta taste my grave you gotta come
over on sunday you gotta chase my grave
you gotta do this you gotta do that
now after 20 years you're telling me
you gotta taste my gravy
so what's the story tell me the whole
[ __ ] story about nikki hot sauce
sauce all right tell me about the
[ __ ] story i started making this
sauce and uh
you know [ __ ] around with it and uh i
first came out to l.a and i
you know i started making it on my own
and sausage and pork and you know it got
better and better over the years
let's open it up
let's put them on there [ __ ] friends and
family and then when i did chuck and
larry
i made some sauce for adam and kevin
james had some of it and he went wild so
who made that i said i did
so then his brother told me why don't we
find a guy to uh mass produce it so
years ago we actually did make the sauce
is this a new old bag this is brand new
this is a sample i'm laughing because
last night my week my friend made a
slice of pizza
sent it to me for christmas
while the show was going we kept looking
i had aluminum fall on it well he kept
looking at it looking at it looking at
it
and he killed it like when the show was
over he just destroyed that slicing but
we had this sauce well let me tell you
years ago right now but we used a
different tomato now this company's
interested so the guy that made it
originally did a new batch of it but it
came out fresher and i think better than
it was even and even you know like my
son had it and he was like wow you know
it's not your typical sauce jar
i'm not to my own horn it's pretty damn
good for a jar in the sauce
thank you sir tremendous
tanya it's a high-end sauce
not cheap to make it either
it's really good very good
yeah there's the cheese in it
what cheese isn't the cheese no no no no
there's high nope
it tastes like there's pomegranate
cheese no that's why you eat that lizard
meat and you don't know what it is so
this is the this is the nicky red sauce
in the jar right now what do you think
it's up there i mean i've tasted a bunch
of high high-end sauces i think this
this they don't even come near this this
is tremendous for a jar sauce right
vegan is a gluten-free well
this one's probably not gluten-free so
that's what this guy now it might be a
little concerned about it but the tomato
he used this pastine tomato
gave it a
fresher feel like a lighter feel
it has a it cooked it with a pork rib
bone but it doesn't stay in there that's
why it's got that that nice flavor
because they use this pork but we could
probably make some without the rib bone
maybe just one with the rib bone and
then the others may be for the
gluten-free people and we can make a few
of those so rib bone is what has gluten
in it
no it makes it not vegan it makes it not
vegan
they don't want that you know they think
it's not you know not healthy that way
but taste the sauce does this uh feel
like pretty healthy to you i think it
does doesn't bother me i don't feel no
essence we taste it again taste it again
you don't know that it didn't leave why
are you sitting there with short arms
taste it y'all look like this thing
wishing you could drink this [ __ ]
thing sure
what are you kidding me i need more
breath
i wouldn't mean he's watching like a
hawk to make sure you don't double dip
yeah what that [ __ ] double what do
you mean everybody gets on me about that
who i don't mind the double dip
everybody yells about yells at me you
got a double now i'm gonna have to
refrigerate it but it's all right we
opened it who cares it's so you like it
right it's [ __ ] pretty good
but we got some money behind it we'll
see really try it again
now if you just have it you don't know
that maybe it was cooked with a rib bone
to me it tastes very
very fresh
that's what i like about it it's not
heavy either
i tried it on pasta it's like the guy
from he's from connecticut this guy john
astarita and called ultimate foods he
goes nick it's one of the best i make
sauces for a lot of people goes your
sauce this one your recipe
one of the best jar sauces now let me
ask you this how much money does it take
to launch a company like this
it takes a decent amount of corn mill
no less than that but half a milk
probably yeah and you're getting into
whole foods yeah those kind of stores i
mean this company that might be
interested in packing it maybe they
would just give me a royalty but if
they'll do everything and put it out
there i could be like you know
be like the paul newman whatever i mean
i'm gonna be as big as paul norman but
i don't mind if they'll you know give me
a decent royalty not just completely i
don't want to just give it away because
it's a good product and from this sauce
we can make
three or four flavors you need a couple
of flavors to be seen because in the
supermarket if you have just one flavor
it'll never find you so you're going to
have three four or five flavors ragu has
ragu right mushrooms basil and tomato or
mushrooms some sauce though yeah but the
sausage
nicky red sauce is holding up [ __ ]
i feel like i'm in prison right now
like we're eating out of a jar of bread
i know but it's great right it's true
yes you dip the [ __ ] sauce you dip
the bread in the
what's better than that
you got more wine joey
huh you gotta show each other at least a
sip of wine with the sauce yeah a little
bit oh my [ __ ] johnny what do you
want no i gotta drive
i'm impressed i'm tired i mean i always
knew it was good but it came out even
better
look at the color of it the color is
[ __ ] good right
it's red for all the audio listeners
it's a really deep rich brand it's nice
it's beautiful yeah tell your fans out
there they would love this sneaky red
sauce so what are the main can can you
tell some of the main ingredients
i can't give away my recipe no no let me
ask you this you have a website and
everything not yet not yet we're working
on it yeah and we'll let you know people
yeah we'll let you know this is a good
[ __ ] sauce thank you
i don't [ __ ] around i mean i'm not going
to put out something i got water for you
you don't have to go down deep you just
say you're not really in cuba we're just
stimulating you know what i'm saying
look at you lee how you feeling what do
you got planned for the weekend
what i got planned for i have a little
bit of work and then uh good [ __ ] huh
you're not ziplining a mini bike riding
i saw this newly zipline i wanted to do
it's so cool
they they they
set you up so you can go like flat and
you zip like flat like an arrow
that's what you need that's right obama
can't drop down
oh there's a there's a there's one in
dallas
but it's only thrills i like i i have to
go there
i'm under the weight thing it's per it's
cool you're never a little weird i am
too
stop bullshitting the last time you
almost took the whole tree down
they threw them out and they wrote yahoo
report on them
yelped them i don't want to eat you cook
joey
no i'm not you don't do anything
you know man i know how to dope up [ __ ]
yeah like when i lived in colorado i
take prego and i put some meat in there
some sausage some onions some garlic
some wine some i just doped up [ __ ] i
don't know how to make something let me
show you this cowboy steak i made the
other night
want to see a [ __ ] pretty steak
what's a cowboy steak it's like a giant
it's a giant uh rib eye they call it
like um they call it a tomahawk steak
but it's [ __ ] big on a big bone two
and a half three pounds and they come
out with it this time of year like
costco had it it's delicious it's some
[ __ ] steak you slice it nice and it's
big but you can't overcook it
i'll show you this thing this is this
thing is freaking nice
let me see you're a chef too yeah i'm
all right make the sauce you act you're
right
you're producing yeah i'm creative you
know father i'm a father a man you're a
man of many [ __ ] look at that bad ass
rip-off that thing is beautiful that's
beautiful right surely he'll [ __ ]
pass out i love everybody
oh yeah it comes on a big stick
two and a half three pounds
and then i made a little a little i made
a little fazel this came out great with
the escudo
that's the best listen you rub that on
your herpes sauce that's right you're
[ __ ] done you got hiv you eat that
[ __ ] you eat that [ __ ] you're done you
want to eat a crack cooker you eat a
pasta fazool you're done now look at the
sauce
system the whole [ __ ] thing that's
what i need that's why i felt a lot of
garlic in the possibility oh yeah and
then i made my my lobster sauce the
other night did you check this shout out
i killed the lobsters then i put them
right in the [ __ ] i buy them live i kill
them and then i put them in the sauce
and the sauce is unbelievable it's
lobster sauce look at that
is that a [ __ ] sauce or whatever you
put the lobsters in this sauce yeah oh
and like that sauce
get the lobsters i have to kill them
first i feel bad and then i crack them
open they get all the lobster juice
basically just put them in the nicky red
sauce and it comes out like an
incredible
lobster
diablo oh that's tremendous over
linguine
to die for some clams
a little shrimp on the side who's better
than you right nobody nobody leave
nobody [ __ ] viagra you get a heart on
for 10 days you got to call the
physician the surgeon yeah the priest
viagra oh my god
what a thing huh what do you got going
on for
talk to me my brother you got the sauce
got the sauce i got this pilot i'm
shooting this month this thing called
over the hill um i wrote bentley evans
aida is going to be in it mikey raps
bunch of people mike store you might
come in and do something at tia carrera
and i got a whole bunch of people that
are gonna be in it so doing that then i
got this movie coming out this month the
warner brothers the justice league i'm a
voice it's a big deal like uh for all
these people they these comic book fans
the dc movie that i did so that's coming
out this month and then next month
there's a little thing called the eyes
that i was in that got a theatrical
release
and then i'm trying to get a
a southern movie off the ground it's
faith-based movie nice script i want to
get it that whole freaking faith-based
crowd
you know there's a lot of opportunities
there but i actually got a nice script
called call me luke you could be good
for something in it yeah it's a good
script
trying to do that for like you know a
small budget but i gotta start you know
i gotta make something i mean that this
other thing i gotta try to sell it i
gotta get my ass
you know my own thing because i i mean i
can do it i just need
the right network the right people to
pick it up and give me a shot she can
make a mill here a mill
you know what's going on over there
you're going through changes you're
going to crush
give me some more sauces over there
you're awesome you want some more lee
sure sure all right
hey you got a boyfriend no you ain't got
a boyfriend why because you're hanging
out with those lemons they're lemons
they're coconuts you hang out with small
people you got small friends you hang
out with yo yo people you get yo yo
friends it's simple mathematics i love
those lines i'm always thinking about
that you ain't got a boyfriend away
because you're hanging out with coconuts
they're coconuts they're lemons
is that one of the best movies rocky the
original rocky it's beautiful like
stallone was so beautiful in that movie
even the way he looked everything he was
so innocent
all right good night marie
there you go lee
thank you sir all right buddy enjoy
yourself
hey pizza's tossed deadly hung it up
guys what's up
house so you guys are special i brought
you guys up here like a [ __ ] sample
jaw
delicious no that's tremendous
i tell you it's great imagine how this
would be on pizza ah a nice little i
don't know if you want to put that on
pizza because it's so good
there's an odd to making pizza too
you know what
i like the new haircut i look younger
don't i i've been going with the
i look younger with the new haircut
unbelievable i can't believe it's been
all those years since we did the movie
oh this guy is sending me all right here
we go these guys are i sent you a
20-page presentation on one of these
days you'll learn to trust me i don't
trust anybody
you know i don't know the food business
it's like poorly goes what do i know
about the restaurant i don't know how to
make a restaurant you want to order and
eat
you know anything about this [ __ ]
joint and he's like
saying he could be there so much that i
could be a stoolie we're watching that
last night with the kids uh watching
good fellas laughed my [ __ ] ass off
that joe pesci
oh my god i'm in the weeds of seahawks
yeah there's big pricks coming around
here i'm resting here saying arresting
yeah i'm resting i love that that movie
every time it comes
it's so funny the movie is so funny it's
become a comedy like scarface yes it's
like facebook
you pee at lines that where you going
man
you're you're chicken
i got a lot of things to do the lines
that are not even jokes
i want to talk to you right now you you
gotta you you want a green card
that's all you gotta do uh what do you
gotta do head go to about
or somebody else yeah
you tell me be a pleasure to kill a
communist if there's a those movies now
oh like for me when i see a time i can
watch it for 10 minutes 15 minutes and i
get sad i know i get really sad i know
you know what that was something that
was great i still remember when that
came out
going to people's houses and staying
there till 8 9 in the morning doing coke
while that movie was on over and over
you know
it's great and it's sad to the ending
you know you feel bad
he go when he went the other night it
was on the other night and he's when
he's telling his sister i'd be with you
i'd be with like a little boy
but you know if he didn't kill manolo
they might have killed all those
ciabattos that's what my father said my
father was funny he used to get into
movies and say nicholas he should have
never killed manolo they would have
killed all those [ __ ] you know
and it's true he's like he never should
have killed his best friend
you know all right they got married
he was all it's all a coke you know
all that cocaine
and [ __ ]
so huh they were like a red sauce yeah
mickey red sauce
sauce
brothers i got to bring johnny into this
let me tell you something if you had
nicki red sauce the acid from the
tomatoes kills the cocaine and makes you
go to sleep right
right that's why you would you have a
slice of pizza to sober up you know why
the oil from the pizza if you eat a
slice of pizza you won't get blasted is
that there's something about pizza and
the oil it'll help you not to get a
hangover or get really blasted have a
slice of pizza before you're going to
the best [ __ ] thing would go to white
castles get 30 belly bombs late at night
i love a white castle two of them is the
limit i guess oh two i got two double
steps we were in seattle you remember
that old place dicks we went up to the
dixie but it's right it's not bad it
ain't it ain't any white castle white
castle you got to get them steamed
that's how you do it yeah i always get
two double steamed yeah french how many
kids pepsi just two belly bombs
my son could probably eat like what ten
he's [ __ ] young i had friends like 45
of them 15 yeah
yeah
yeah
when you're [ __ ] 18 you could eat 20
of those you got a big appetite
i don't even want to ask how many elite
could eat i don't like them i don't
think that i don't like onions really
you don't like onions
how you feeling brother you all right
uh-huh
i'm starting to go through changes he's
going through changes i see him now boy
you ready for another star sure why not
[ __ ] it you eat the sauce the sauce is
[ __ ] delicious i can't even just put
them in there it's delicious delicious
thank you tell your listeners nikki red
sauce
follow me
follow me on twitter
you know what i mean you guys gotta
this thing is gonna be good we need the
support sitting here
and
i really don't like sauce that's not
warm ever yeah i was gonna and i just
like you know what i'm gonna try it cold
sometimes you have a sauce
and you could t it's too olivey it's two
of these you guys want to taste it it's
two of that
get a piece of bread hurry up before i
kill that [ __ ] when i was their
age i would have never liked
just tomato sauce on bread oh this is
delicious
this is how you eat manly
eat like a champ over here that's good
this is old school [ __ ] peasant type
[ __ ] yeah
that's what we do you know bet the
project out put the mozzarella bottle of
wine
[Music]
we'll be back next week people i love
you at all my my [ __ ] heart like i
said calusa sold out but i'm in
cleveland at hilarity starting next
thursday
nick tutura once you get the sauce going
and we'll bring you back on
it's delicious thank you you know i
wouldn't even bring i don't bring food
people never
your family you said it's the best it's
the best jack thank you bro lee what do
you got going on this weekend what are
you gonna do you got a zip line
no longer you're not going back to long
beach to the zoo you left your hat
no i'm i'm
uh you know the traveling man this
weekend not traveling all right i love
you [ __ ] uh oh hold on let's go
let's do uh real quick listen people you
know i don't play games with you guys
i've had this thing for three months now
and i love it
hellotushy.com oh why do i love it
because it's a big day what does a bidet
do i let uncle joey tell you it shoots
hot water in your muffler okay
that's it think about that right now
take a minute right now rest for five
minutes close your eyes
and think of hot water sprinkling up
into your muffler every morning to start
your day after coffee because usual all
right you sit down
you get a little coffee you smoke a
cigar cigarette
right you take your heart blood pressure
medication
you smoke a joint maybe two
and right away you gotta go to the
bathroom
right there you go maybe maybe i'm
missing something on the news but when
you sit down now
at the end of that 20 minutes
you just turn around boom
and who's there for you hellotushy.com
sprinkling water into your little
muffler
like a sprinkle you know what i'm saying
it's like a sprinkler without the
mexican just sprinkling water into your
muffler you get up you wipe it with
their new towel
go to hellotushy.com they got a little
towel that's got
different aromas and i forget what the
name of it was i used it two times my
wife washed it she didn't give it back
to me but it's [ __ ] tremendous you
understand me
it avoids bacteria it avoids crotch rot
and just your ass won't smell no more we
all have that problem don't be ashamed
you know you want to go out and let six
in the morning you're going to a bar at
eight o'clock at night what the [ __ ] do
you think yes i was gonna smell like
it's polluted it's balloon it smells
like tony montana's wife
you know what i'm saying
that's where hello tushie comes in hello
tushy's portable and you have to 60 day
guarantee do me a favor go to
hellotuition.com right now and press in
hellotutor.com church i believe
hellotushy.com slash church and get what
lee 10 off 10 off all right again you
got a 60 day warranty i love the [ __ ]
thing they've sold thousands of them i
get emails every week people are happy
they take pictures with the box you'll
be happy also also on it.com [ __ ]
go there right now you're making your
little resolutions you want to eat
better you want a sling dick it starts
at honey.com whether it's the alpha
brain or the hem force protein or the
mike dolce protein or the the new mood
or the shroom tech sport they got you
covered go to honor.com and look at all
the great supplements they have right
now go to the box and press in church
boom get 10 off
your first order deliver right to your
[ __ ] door all right
and then basically that's it that's our
show tonight again go to honor.com and
go to hellotushy.com and press in
church and on both church church and get
10 percent off your order with a 60-day
warranty it's a beautiful thing
for your [ __ ] to be clean all right
have a great weekend i love you guys
i'll see you monday stay black and have
a phenomenal weekend all right don't
forget about me beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
you